for his performance in the Silence of
the Lambs last year he received an Oscar
this year he received a knighthood
which means he not only dines with the
royal family but on the royal family
please welcome sir Hannibal Lecter
himself Sir Anthony Hopkins
good evening it's good to be here again
the year has gone very fast I must have
been very difficult for the Academy to
choose an actress from this year's most
formidable group of talents great
actresses all of them and they are
cutting the nerve nan de xin Mary
McDowell and passion fish
Michelle Pfeiffer Love Field
Susan Sarandon Lorenzo's oil
Emma Thompson and Howard's ed
and the Oscar goes to Emma Thompson
um and ladies and gentlemen I really
don't know how to thank the Academy not
only for this but also um for this view
because then it's overwhelming to see so
many faces who've entertained and
influenced me and thrilled me all my
life and it just takes my breath away um
and if I could thank you all I would but
I I have more pressing debts to AM
Forster for creating Margaret Schlegel
to James ivory for asking me to play her
to Ismail merchant for paying me to play
her it feels really unnecessary at this
moment actually I think I might have to
give back the money
um and - Ruth - Ruth Prowler dibala for
her flawless adaptation to work
suppurative cast and crew to Sony
Pictures Classics for their dedication
and commitment and especially to Sir
Anthony Hopkins for being like this
the night of my life and finally I would
like if I may to dedicate this Oscar to
the heroism and the courage of women and
to hope that it inspires the creation of
more true screen heroines to represent
them thank you so much
Elizabeth Taylor engine
Gary and gene Hackman are coming up on
the attack
or